there's so much stuff here and all of
this is boba themed this is honestly
like a boba lovers dream
hey guys it's dick so I'm here in Taipei
Taiwan I'm supposed to being on vacation
but I found this really cool spot that I
really wanted to share with you guys so
here I am at the Regent Hotel you're
doing this boba festival event that's
kind of like a boba extravaganza where
they designed an entire menu that
features boa in every way you can
possibly imagine we're talking
croissants we're talking pizza we're
talking calzones
there's 14 items here 14 items at Peter
boba that's insane I would try all 14
but an eight-course boba meal is pretty
intense right I also love boba I already
guys to live through this experience
with me let's get our Bobo on the first
one we have here is a boba tiramisu chef
Ondrea demonstrated the entire making
process but you can see how like it's
super intricate it looks super good oh
she's gonna dig right in I think that's
a really big bite Oh super good the
coffee flavor like really comes through
right away and this is this part it's so
fluffy the moment I put it in my mouth
it literally just melts right away you
get that perfect thinner sweetness the
boba is super chewy super QQ it actually
matches this really well this is really
good I know this is just the first
course I should stop eating this I put
that one aside this is our second dish
this is the matcha croissant super
indulgent it's practically losing boba
out if I do that oh that's so good I'm
gonna put that bobo back in there
I love croissants I love matcha I love
boba
those sorts not perfectly so chewy
because of the girl but it's not too
sweet and I also like talked about how I
was watching chef Ondrea make this he
had a bowl of piping bag I've seen
piping bags with whipped cream a piping
bag full of boba just so you can cram
them as much boba and here as you can
that's pretty dope really loaded of this
bite so here we go this is this is great
prashant also super flaky their offers
sort of like a neutral palate that
really complements like the soft
sweetness of the boba and the matcha and
just take a look at this like how how
amazing does this look this is one of
those cases where it tastes basically as
good as it looks there's a third item
that we're trying there's so much of
what we got on this look at this
Wow it's perfectly smooth out this is
milk tea cream if you transformed a cup
of boba tea into cake this is exactly
what it would look like this is
incredible absolutely it is probably the
item I was looking forward to the most
I also just watched chef Ondrea squeeze
on morph OVA so that was delightful and
go in for it oh wait it's so soft
oh boy this is an 8 bobba avalanche into
the GoBot and then you can see how again
we can help fluffy that is this is
definitely my favorite one so far this
cream maybe because it's milk tea
flavored the aftertaste of it really
does feel like I just drank the milk tea
a lot more food but this was so good
look I'm to see a mola one of my friends
Jasmine really likes boa tea she's gonna
be so excited to see this now for our
fourth course here they are I was greedy
and I'm trying all three of these this
one is a sparkling tip why do you drink
tieguanyin is a type of boolong which is
really big here in Taiwan there's a bit
of dried food up here too I already know
I'm gonna love this this one is an
ailment coffee drink up I'll shake it up
in a bit this one is a caramel soy milk
it looks like a regular milk tea right
now but I'm sure it'll be a flavor
explosion starting with the caramel so
now what's really cool about this is you
can actually leave with these musical
bottles I was expecting this to be
really sweet maybe because I saw caramel
and I expect a lot of caramel syrup it
actually is a very very subtle sweetness
which I really appreciate the soy milk
it goes really well with Bobo I'm not a
big common person but I love coffee the
texture of this is a lot thicker than I
was expecting it to be you don't get
that like piercing taste of almond syrup
because they make their own almond milk
there with three types of elements
element people out there this is
probably the dream drink and after the
one I'm most excited about not shake it
because I don't want it to bubble out
like crazy even though it is already
doing that this is definitely the drink
for me you get that fruitiness the
bubbliness I'm getting the best of all
the world's learning number four right
now guys I have four more items to go I
feel like I've already had a cups worth
of boba so far we've done a bunch of
sweets now to do some savory things this
my friends is a who that's hi this my
friends is a calzone this is how big it
is it is filled with boba I've seen the
caramel sauce I can also see these
little Parmesan cheese bits calzone and
boba who would have thought open up what
is that boba and cheese oh it smells
like and marshmallow look about it
can we just talk about this moment here
this moment of cheese and boba coming
out of the calzone
this is incredible I get everything in
here there's a lot of chewiness going on
in here because of the cheese and the
boba feel like at this point I don't
know what I'm eating I feel like when I
put it in my mouth it kind of melted
into one I'm gonna make a little bite
here
here's that bite all right cheers Cheers
- nobody cheers it's a little cooler now
so I feel like I can taste the layers a
little bit more stop sweetness at the
sauce the savoriness from the cheese I
know the concept of it sounds really
weird but it kind of works with the
force done Jose I'm getting really full
here I feel like I'm like 85% over right
now already we have this boba pizza here
boba and marshmallows and caramel syrup
and cheese spoken pizza is again one of
those things that I would have never
even dreamed of I love that they have
that concept here I'm not sure how this
is going to taste like but it looks
fantastic
oh yeah this is what his legs looks like
my mind is like very confused right now
feel like this is a combination of like
a s'more bubble tea and people dessert
pizzas are becoming a things you do have
that cheese to add like that savory
element so it kind of does work next
time you guys want a dessert pizza
public needs up like just either way to
go are you guys I am in boba zone right
now
I'm like days because of how much boba
I've had two more to go two more to go
this is the charcoal custard bun with
boba you guys ready for the reveal
oh this is so pretty
yo this is not what I was expecting at
all ooh it's so soft oh my god I almost
dropped it this is why I can't have good
things for those of you who don't know
what custard buns are they are a very
popular item in dim sum places usually
it's white what's inside is this sweet
and sometimes savory custard we're gonna
open this up right now so you do see the
yoki bits maybe a little bit so then you
see a bunch of boba here it smells super
custardy I'm excited to try this again
it's salty and sweet I already knew
there was boba in here the chewiness
still takes me by surprise but I would
say visually this is stunning I'm going
to set this aside and get ready for our
last course
[Music]
this is our last course of the meal
there's a lot going on here I want to
show you guys what kind of toppings we
have here there's taro
there's boba what we call human it's
like made from both taro FC potatoes
this is barley kidney beans peanuts red
bean and mung bean it also comes with
two different types of tea
Thai tea and then this one's Earl Grey
tea I'm gonna go with Earl Grey because
it's a little less sweet this my friends
this massive thing right here is a
bubble I spot they're shaped ice beneath
all of this so instead of hot rock you
get a bunch of shaved ice in Taiwan
shaved ice is like such a big thing I
will say though I have never seen shaved
ice serve like this this is super cool
you get a little bit of everything in
here boba in so this is what my bowl
looks like right now it doesn't look as
fancy anymore but that's only because I
mixed all the good stuff in there final
course my friends here we go in one bite
you're getting so much variety this is
like a friggin treasure box a lot of
these toppings are the traditional
toppings that go on tommy shaved ice I
love that they like kind of took that
modern take and evolved it into this
incredible-looking dessert last bite ova
it's only right great that I end this
meal with another bite of boba all right
guys the eight course meal is done I'm
definitely a little bit open out you had
to tell me to pick your favorite though
I'm obsessed with this cake I am super
happy that I got to try this a mobo
feast today this is honestly like a
bubble over stream I am now going to
pack all of this up and bring it home
and share it with my family and friends
I brought my beau levesque but clearly
I'm gonna need a much bigger back to
take everything out really hoping that
you guys can come check out some of
these amazing boba treats here and uh
see you guys next time back in New York
[Music]